you know the world has changed and it
has school has become an abnormal
setting for children and instead of
admitting that we say the children are
abnormal we say the children we need to
correct the children hi I'm Nick
Gillespie with reason today we're
talking with Peter gray he's a
psychologist at Boston College and he
writes a lot about childhood and the
loss and decline of play Peter thanks
for talking to us I'm very glad to be
here so in your book from 2013 was
called free to learn why unleashing the
instinct to play will make our children
happier more self-reliant and better
students for life you also did a widely
viewed TEDx talk when you talk about
play and the importance of it for
children or actually for our species
explain what your what's going on there
yeah well first of all I'm talking about
play I'm talking about what some people
would call free play but to me it's not
play if it's not free so I tend to leave
out that so that's it and I mean
specifically this is not okay you come
home from school you're your
ten-year-old kid you put on your uniform
and you go to a four-hour pratt and
that's run but that is not that's not
what I regard is play that the primary
characteristics of play are that it's
self chosen and self directed play is
how children learn to direct their own
activities how learn they learn to
create activities it's how they learn to
negotiate differences with their
playmates all of that is destroyed when
you've got an adult running at rooks so
play is a children's play as a child
chose a child directed at and you talked
about this in the context of mammals
this play is not something that is
simply observed in humans or upper
primates as far as we know all young
mammals play and they play at those
activities that are the biggest
constraints to survival and reproduction
so predators play at predation prey
animals play fleeing and dodging get
away from predators you can pretty much
predict what an animal will play I know
I
the things that it has to learn in order
to survive and talk about why as part of
it is that you you learn how to escape
predation but you also learn how to
create a world and negotiate the world
well human beings have so much more to
learn than any other mammals and it's
not surprising therefore that what I've
learned from anthropologists is that
throughout time and across culture where
children are free to play they play way
way more than any other mammals do and
they play a much larger variety of ways
not just in the kinds of physical ways
that other animals do but human beings
play at all if you think about all the
kinds of things that human beings
everywhere has to learn we have to learn
language we have to learn how to build
things use these opposable thumbs we
have to learn how to get aligned with
our peers we have to learn how to
control our emotions children are
playing in ways that promote all of
those kinds of things and they're also
playing you know the children come into
the world biologically predisposed to
look around and see what other people
are doing in their culture and to see
what are the tools in the culture that
you have to master and children play at
those things so children in a hunting
hunter-gatherer culture play with bows
and arrows and digging sticks and dugout
canoes and so on children in our culture
quite naturally are attracted computers
the main tool of our culture farming
cultures they play at the farm using
farming implements so children are
naturally drawn to those kinds of skills
and activities that seem important to
their culture and play at those things
now you chart a decline in free play and
free kind of just hangout time where
kids are left alone and are
self-directed and kind of
self-organizing what are that what are
the indicators of decline you know
what's what's your baseline year and
then how do you bring it to them yeah I
mean there are different ways that
people have tried to quantify this and
it's difficult to quantify but
the historian Howard chuda cough was
written a book on the history of play in
America he talks about the first half of
the 20th century as being the Golden Age
of children's play because by the
beginning of the century there was the
child labor had been more or less it
certainly reduced so children began to
have a lot of free time and parents
adults in general society in general had
not begun to usurp that free time for
other purposes schools of course existed
but we're not nearly the big thing they
are yeah well one of the refrain in your
work is we need less school which of
course makes you a heretic you know
you're going to be burned at the stake
one of the things that I find really
interesting about your work is that it
both elaborates but it's predicated upon
me I do the childhood is kind of
invented we take whatever we're living
in as well this is the natural order of
things but if you look at childhood in
1900 was different than 1800 or day you
know and it's different now there's less
free time for kids less non adult
supervised time the effects of this
decline suicide rates what else and and
how do we grasp this is bad right well
first let me say that the decline in
play has been a gradual decline
sometimes we think of it all it's all
happened to the last 10 or 20 years but
really it's been a gradual decline since
about the mid 1950s and over this same
period of time that there's been this
gradual decline in play there are
well-documented gradual but ultimately
huge increases in a variety of mental
disorders of childhood especially
depression and anxiety now of course
when people hear this the first
objection people raise as well we
weren't looking for depression and
anxiety back then but in fact there are
certain standardized questionnaires such
as the Minnesota multiphasic personality
inventory which has a depression scale
built into it there's a version of this
for adolescent aged kids and that's been
unchanged has been given a normative
groups of young people over
over the decades since actually the late
1930s and you look at that scale and you
look at the cutoff on that scale that
would be suspected major depression
today and what you find is there's about
an Eightfold increase in the rate of
major depression among young people aged
14 to 18 or so what you talk about the
multipliers of that though is it that it
goes from point one tenth of one percent
to one percent
it go or is it it goes from about as it
turns out about one percent to about
eight percent about it that's quite
remarkable isn't about eight percent of
young people today qualify as well is
that is part of that because depression
and anxiety are luxury goods and that in
1950s America we didn't we get beyond
not looking for it or understanding and
in the same way we do now but it's also
like with literally almost we are
figuratively I guess we couldn't afford
it well that's a that's an interesting
question I don't think it works that way
and the reason I don't think it works
that way is that this this increase in
depression increase in anxiety and I
could talk about some other yes orders
as well has been pretty much a linear
increase over this period of time and it
doesn't correlate with economic cycles
it doesn't correlate with Wars it
doesn't correlate you know kids are much
more anxious today than they were in the
1950s and 60s when we believe the
Russians are going to attack us
you know kids are much kids are more
good value you know with the Russians
are going to attack us now right yeah
that's right active that again but you
know some people talk about well maybe
it's the divorce rate maybe it's other
things related to the family but divorce
is really peaked in the 1970s and this
did not peak in 1986 according to a
report I read it was about 13 kids
adolescents
per 100,000 and 1986 committed suicide
it went down to 10.5 in 1999 and it's
back up to 13 per 100,000 so that's you
know I mean that's a 30-year period
where you see a decline in an increase
so that fits into Europe it was in a way
I mean it's interesting that suicide
tended to decline most people don't even
though depression wasn't declining and I
think most people tribute that decline
to the increase in psychoactive drugs to
suicide prevention programs a lot of
effort began to be put into that and now
despite the fact that we still have that
suicided run back up again so but of
course suicide is just the tip of the
iceberg it's not yeah and well and talk
about the increase in you know when we
talk about drugs I mean adderall ritalin
zoloft all the antidepressants most of
those did not exist and anything
approaching current form until the 70s
and 80s or even later how is that
factoring into I in a kind of way that
would be more akin to a Michel Foucault
or Thomas saws are we medicating our
children proactively now in a way that
destroys their ability to have free play
well you know that's an interesting
question which I've given some thought
on there's not a whole lot of research
on it but it is interesting that the
stimulant drugs that are used to treat
ADHD if you give them to young rats you
knock out play and I've note I happen to
have known some kids who are on the
drugs and what they tell me is they
don't feel as playful they don't feel
like they're themselves with the drug
that I don't hear that from everybody
and they affect different people in
different ways but one theory is that
what the drug does what the ADHD
treatments are doing is that they are
decreasing that drive to play and that
drive to do creative and spontaneous
self-chosen things which then makes it
more possible for you to sit in your
seat and do what you're told to do you
know it's it's really quite a
following that at some point in their
career in their school career 20 percent
of boys are getting a diagnosis of ADHD
and a good most of them are being put on
these powerful drugs where we don't
really know what the long-term effects
and and do you think that's a change in
in the background in the somatic
behavior you know a reality of children
or is it just that's a place where you
know the kids are probably squirming in
a CDS interrupting too much so you zap
them with that I mean is or does not
reflect in actual physical change in
that's that's a great class I think it's
primarily a change in schools you know
remember I described school when I was
in school never it's nobody expected us
to sit in there right more than an hour
at a time you know the world has changed
and it has school has become an abnormal
setting for children and instead of
admitting that we say the children are
abnormal we say the children we need to
correct the children rather than to the
corrective space and it's no surprise
that it's mostly boys boys have always
been more rambunctious less less willing
to conform than girls on average yeah
and schools I and part of you know part
of your argument which i think is is
intuitively persuasive is the idea that
school is becoming more and more wood I
guess nobody uses this term anymore but
it's a total institution it you know it
controls more and more aspects of the
people who are in it it has expanded a
unit you go to school early you stay
later you're in after school or
preschool programs which are basically
the same thing what is driving beyond
you know what is driving the expansion
of making sure that our kids are
supervised by adults all of the time
yeah I I think there's really a number
of factors driving that part of it is
the momentum of the schooling
establishment itself any kind of
business wants to expand right you Lana
we want to be able to hire more people
do more things you know and so school
has been very successful in that and I
think one of the things that school
teaches there
very well is that you need school in
order to learn and so products of
schooling feel like okay the way that my
child is going to learn is by school
even more schooling that I had right and
so the parents get behind it and this is
I mean it start we don't necessarily
look in in 1960 maybe 5% or 10% of
Americans had a college degree maybe not
even as many yeah in 1970 was probably
15 or it was higher now it's two-thirds
of graduating high school seniors go on
to college so yeah rank litera
perpetuates its own extreme to believe
that a college degree is essential to a
successful adult life and in some ways
that belief is a self-fulfilling
prophecy right and so so that's happened
so people believe they've got to get
their kids into college people believe
they've got to get their kids into a
good college whatever that means and you
gotta get in better got more schooling
interests all and a good and you've got
to take the honors courses and the
advanced placement courses you hit boom
has to be pure now you can a fanzine or
booze or play you're thinking about your
kids college education before the kid is
even born
yeah how much of that is driven or I
guess what I'm thinking is the kind of
panopticon's state foreign children how
much of that is just the fact that you
know in by 1950 women went back into the
workforce in a big way in a way they the
female labor force participation was
rising until the depression World War
two and then it dropped and then it
started going back up again and is it
just that parents aren't around
typically you know in your and my
childhood where it would be common for
the mother to be home you had somebody
to watch the kids kind of at least
absent mindedly and when women are
working and everybody's pursuing a
career you what do you do you really
want to leave your kids at home yeah I
think that certainly plays a role in the
historical change that occurred when
women went to work that was a great
thing because women were
pennant on oftentimes abusive husbands I
don't want to go back to that yeah for
certainly most men and even if it is
just to be right to express themselves
through viable workers but we never we
never figured out what we're going to do
about the kids that we never as a
culture figure that out and so as a
result we had this period of time women
we're working kids were coming home kids
were now in what probably in many cases
was a left less safe environment
suddenly you began hearing now whether
there was an actual increase or not at
least you began hearing more about
things happening to kids and and then
you began to have public service
announcements do you know where your
child is going and suddenly the whole
the whole by the way if you were a good
if you were a smart kid your parents had
no idea of course not and and when I was
a kid parents didn't want to know
whether I just wanted another initiative
they don't come back
they don't wanted them out of the house
and you know so so those things have
changed and and my argument is there's
nothing about today's world that should
be preventing free play for children
it's just that we can't expect it to
happen in the same way that it happened
in the 1950s we've got to figure out how
to allow it to happen first of all we've
got to come we've got to come to some
sense of sanity about schooling I mean
we really truly become insane in this
drive to believe that children need so
much schooling I think even the people
who are pushing their children for more
schooling don't see schooling as how
they're really learning skills they need
for life they just see it as this is
what you need to do to get into the next
level of school things run and then you
need to do that to get into the next
level then ultimately at some point in
your life now you're going to be able to
get a job and live your life
you run this argument by the powers up
there Boston College I can't imagine
that oh you know there I haven't tried
to talk about the college out of going
exist right so how well to extend it and
in the subtitle of the book you talked
about how play will make our children
happier more self-reliant and better
students for life is there a cost to
when kids leave the structured
environment of schooling and school like
institutions when they start working do
they do kids who haven't played do they
fall apart in a way because they're not
used to that more open-ended we're doing
more and more evidence for that's true
and in fact we're hearing more and more
evidence of kids falling apart when they
go to college a couple years ago I was
invited by the head of the counseling
service at Boston College to join him
and some discussions with faculty and
counselors about what was happening
there and he said that in the last five
years there had been a doubling of the
use of the counseling facilities he
believed that prior to that there was
also increases over the course of time
and it turns out that this is not
happening just at Boston College it's
happening at colleges across the country
students are going off to college for
the first time even though they're
connected to their parents by cell phone
if they are in some sense more
independent than they have been before
us is where you go don't become your
son's band now they're and now they are
having psychological breakdowns about
things that in the past would have been
regarded as bumps in the road of life
you know we've all got problems we've
got to solve our problems as my job to
solve it
roommate disputes breakup of a romantic
relationship that great I was going to
say in a mine I mean - so you know never
got an A - before I'm not allowed to get
an A - I think before we talk about what
is to be done yeah let me push back in
two broad ways and the verse and I say
this as somebody who's written a you
know in a parallel way obviously less a
substantial way than yourself but you
know we we have this ridiculous outsized
belief that our kids you know the minute
they're out of our sights are going to
be kidnapped
put on a milk carton somewhere yeah you
know where they're going to die from
eating hot dogs and get cancer by the
time they're I mean we just have a
ridiculous outside sense of risk all of
that is true
but it's like come on being a kid now
like think of it you know it's got to be
so much better than it was when I was
growing up in the 70s my father grew up
in the 30s and was working and was you
know there were creepy people all around
all the time you know if you're gay if
you're a sensitive child today you can
read and not be made fun of nobody calls
people four-eyes anymore there is less
beatings in childhood you know according
to the federal stats how can you can you
really say childhood is a grimmer place
and it was yeah I mean while I agree
with the things that you've described
there have been improvements in many
many ways
I wouldn't want to go back to the 1950s
the prejudices they existed you know the
physical beating of children was still
every ounce of meanness and to go on a
social circle but on the other hand this
is really for this is really across
ethnic groups children were happier than
and why were they happier that despite
the fact that their parents might have
been less nice to them than parents are
today they were happier than because
they were spending lots of time with
their peers outdoors playing children
are biologically designed to do that
it's as important to them as eating it's
as important to that to their
development this is what children are
designed to do it's not just what
children did during the first half of
the 20th century in America it's what
children did during most of human
history part of my work has been to look
at hunter-gatherer bands not directly
but by interviewing anthropologists
hunter-gatherer children are playing and
exploring largely away from adults in
age mixed groups essentially all the
time from about age four to the late
teenage years this is how they learn
what they need to learn this is the
natural way that children develop when
we began to take that away then children
were being deprived of something that in
their Bo
in their gut in every part of their DNA
is driving them to do that
and now they can't do it how does how do
computer games particularly networked
computer games I have two boys 29:15
they have a community around computer
games online games is that in your
estimation is that a kind of callback to
a to a good set of activities or is it
to intermediated by whether it's
corporations or technology or screen
driven yeah I think computer play and
and social media as well is the saving
grace without that our kids would be
truly deprived of the opportunity to be
kids because you know they can't get
together in the real world and they
can't get away from adults supervisors
in the real world but they can do it
online so well let's talk about what is
to be done you talked about we've got to
roll back the school state the kind of
school industrial complex how do we go
about doing that and then how do we go
about kind of recovering the
institutions or the social structures
that allow for our children to play yeah
well first of all I think I think that
there's sort of two different lines that
I would talk about here the first is
that if we're talking about conventional
schools we're talking people whose kids
are in schools I think there's more and
more beginning to be more recognition
partly from lenore scan Daisy's writing
and other people who are writing about
worrying about prearranged children and
so on I think there's more and you hear
read more articles about it even schools
themselves they sometimes conventional
schools are inviting me to go and speak
there to parents to teachers about how
kids need play and they're really
examining should we be cutting out some
of this homework shouldn't we be putting
less stress on our kids they're
beginning to recognize wasn't there was
a recent American
psychological association study that
showed that our children are more
stressed than their parents are that
they would rather have a job like their
parents than be going to school they
would be happier with that parents are
beginning to realize that way you know
we did away with child labor but we put
kids into this situation that in some
ways it's over you want to want to pre
kids back inside where you wanted to
help them that's that's what I'm getting
you want to put kids back in factories
so no it's the kids back in factories
but we want to ease up on the factory
life of schooling give them more recess
from that not not just recess but more
time off after school recess this is the
ideal opportunity for play because it's
pretty much age age segregated you're in
this confined space it's so on and so
forth but we need so and also schools
could become places for play I mean
think about it after that period after
school from three o'clock until the
parents are out of school what if you
just opened up the school for free plan
could the age mix you could combine the
elementary school across the street in
the middle school and even the high
school they could be you've got all
kinds of opportunity you've got
playgrounds you've got sometimes
swimming pools it could just be opened
up by me when you're talking us so the
kids are going to be dying they're going
to be drowning they're going to be
breaking their bones there's going to be
sexual problems I mean this is a these
are the arguments against that right
that is a legal liability slider that
you're telling me this is what people
fear but of course that's not going to
happen and you undoubtedly
you're going to have to have a couple of
adults you can't have just one these
days you've got to have a couple of them
and you've got to have probably maybe a
couple responsible teenagers and their
British supervising things make things
they're safe so that's that's one of the
ways to kind of change the into the
character of a school institution what
else what else do we well the other
thing that the other relman which much
of my work is oriented towards I've been
interested in kids who aren't going to
school at all kids who are home-schooled
but to our home school by the method
called on the school caller called I'm
schooling a know particularly like that
term
but that's the term often used these are
young people who are in charge of their
own education and the parents do a good
job of helping them find what they need
to do to pursue their interests I've
also studied graduates of this very
radically alternative school called the
Sudbury Valley School in Massachusetts
it's been around almost 450 years now
has hundreds of graduates this is a
school that is unlike typical schools as
you can imagine all the rules of the
school are made by vote by the whether
you're four years old or a teenage
student kids are not segregated by age
there's no classes offered if kids want
to get together and form a class and
invite a staff member to lead it though
staff members willing to do it but
basically it's a setting where children
are pursuing their own interests in
their own ways and remarkably you know
we think that missing a couple of weeks
of school is going to set you way behind
I mean here our kids missing the whole
damn thing right they're missing the
whole thing and they don't have
difficulty going on to college if that's
what they decide they want to do they go
out into all kinds of careers there's
nothing that demonstrates more clearly
to me that we're just wasting a lot of
kids time making them do all this stuff
in school by force by reward and
Punishment
which is very inefficient learning most
of which they forget right after the
test and if you don't do that and you
just let you just I don't believe you I
don't I don't believe you just turn kids
out on the street but if you provide the
kind of setting that it optimizes their
ability to educate themselves they do it
so much more joyfully so much more
efficiently and so I actually think that
in the longer term the change is going
to occur not by virtue of the schools
themselves changing I just think that's
the school industrial complex if you
want to call it that that it there's so
much economic incentive
there's so much momentum associated with
it inertia associated with any real
change I don't think it's capable of the
kind of real change that I'm talking
about but I think what's happening is
more and more people are leaving it
that's documented or every four years
the US government does a survey of where
kids are going to school and every time
they do the survey a higher percentage
are not sending it's something like four
percent now of American schoolchildren
are in home schooling and that's that
has been every time I do that it's a
it's a it's a rising increase so it's
the right of exit and so it's the right
of exit and at some point I think there
will be enough people doing this that
there will now be a voting bloc that
says look if we're going to spend public
money on education let's not spend all
of that public money on these courses
institutions let's spend some of it on
providing more educational opportunities
so children whose parents can't afford
something like a Sudbury school which is
way less expensive than those private
schools but still part of some room can
do it all right well what we will leave
it there that's a great small L
libertarian approaches to education and
childhood thank you we have been talking
with Peter gray he's a Boston College
psychologist is the author of free to
learn why unleashing the instinct to
play will make our children happier more
self-reliant and better students for
life and do check out his fantastic TEDx
talking on the decline of play Peter
thanks so much for talking to Reason
thank you I'm delighted to talk with you
for reason I'm Nick Gillespie thanks for
watching and thanks for listening
[Music]